[Música]
hola esto es aquí américa el magazine de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente yo soy natalia cabrera y hoy
recorremos las américas de norte a sur
así
empezamos en eeuu porque el gobernador
del estado de la florida durán de santis
promulgó la ley conocida como no digas
gay que prohíbe hablar de derechos el
eje bético en las aulas de un estado que
acoge a muchos de los latinos que
llegaron allí huyendo precisamente de la
persecución en sus países les contamos
desde miami y seguimos nuestro recorrido
en centroamérica en el salvador porque
los ciudadanos denuncian cientos de
detenciones arbitrarias tras la
activación del estado de excepción por
parte del presidente en bucle con el
argumento de luchar contra el aumento en
la tasa de homicidios sus detractores
consideran que se trata de una
estrategia para seguir acumulando el
poder
y luego vamos al sur a argentina porque
el presidente alberto fernández y su
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner ya no se hablan por desacuerdos
en lo pactado con el fondo monetario
internacional mientras que en las calles
los ciudadanos también se dividen entre
los que apoyan al mandatario y quienes
siguen a la ex primera dama
y vamos de inmediato al norte del
continente para empezar el gobernador de
florida ron de santis firmó la polémica
ley que prohíbe enseñar sobre
orientación sexual e identidad de género
en instituciones educativas la normativa
calificada por sus detractores como no
digas gay restringe estos temas hasta
tercer grado una medida que genera
preocupación para los defensores de los
derechos humanos especialmente porque
muchos latinos huyen de sus países de
origen hacia estados unidos esperando
supuestamente mayor protección el
informe es de nuestro corresponsal en
miami anthony welt
hace 22 años que harían al ir una mujer
transgénero llego a estados unidos
huyendo de la discriminación la
violencia y el acoso por su condición
sexual en perú dejó su país convencida
de que no iba a tener oportunidades de
ejercer su profesión de abogada yo soy
el vivo ejemplo de la mujer transgénero
latinoamericana que nace en países que
tienen
regímenes o
gobiernos que no apoyan la inclusión de
las personas transgénero o la identidad
de género
su caso no es aislado por eso fundó su
propia organización en miami para ayudar
a otras personas de américa latina que
han sufrido situaciones similares
su amiga frida es una de ellas y suele
acudir habitualmente al centro para
abordar los problemas del colectivo en
latinoamérica el ser transexual es una
mancha tan grande de discriminación de
violencia de género tan impresionante el
70 por ciento de los niños que se
identifican como transgénero sufren
violencia en sus propios hogares el 90%
termina dedicándose al trabajo sexual y
su expectativa de vida en la región es
de sólo 35 años no sólo estamos creando
asesinatos sino dificultades en el
acceso a la educación dificultades en el
acceso a poder tener trabajo digno
argentina bolivia colombia costa rica
ecuador uruguay y algunos estados de
méxico han impulsado legislaciones para
proteger a la comunidad lgtb de cv y
garantizar sus derechos fundamentales
pero falta mucho por hacer
este retroceso también se está viendo en
estados unidos por ejemplo florida a
finales de marzo se aprobó una
legislación para evitar que se hable de
la condición sexual en las escuelas la
ley se conoce como no tica es gay y está
sucediendo que cuando tienen 10 y 11
años tienen
una confusión tal que quieren a veces
ser el sexo opuesto a que ellos son y
eso es sencillamente poco lo que le han
estado enseñando en las escuelas
muchos creen que esta ley podría ser el
primer paso para arrebatar derechos del
colectivo lgtb como en eeuu y que esa
tendencia se traslade a otros estados
conservadores del país se convertiría
dicen en términos de derechos de
identidad de género de nuevo a la
casilla de salida
y sigamos nuestro recorrido en
centroamérica que toma medidas ante la
eventual llegada de cientos de
pandilleros que huyen del estado de
excepción en el salvador impuesto por
nadie bukele guatemala y honduras
reforzaron sus controles fronterizos
para hacer frente al éxodo mientras que
en el salvador denuncian detenciones
arbitrarias y abusos policiales la
medida fue solicitada por el presidente
buscarle con el supuesto objetivo de
detener el abrupto aumento en la tasa de
homicidios atribuidos a las pandillas
los derechos fundamentales están en
pausa en el salvador el presidente nayib
uke el argumento la decisión en el
repunte en la tasa de homicidios 80 en
48 horas a manos de las pandillas que
tienen alrededor de 70 mil miembros y se
financian a través de homicidios
extorsiones narcotráfico y otras
actividades ilegales
armados con rifles de asalto y chalecos
antibalas policías y soldados patrullan
ahora las calles salvadoreñas la medida
preocupa a organizaciones defensoras de
los derechos humanos que lo ven como un
intento más de bucle de acumular poder
el gobierno del presidente evo que le
debe tomar pasos serios y que respetan
los derechos para gestionar la atroz
violencia de las pandillas en el
salvador en vez de proteger a los
salvadoreños este amplio estado de
emergencia es una receta para el
desastre que pone sus derechos en riesgo
mientras que familiares de los detenidos
se apilan en los alrededores de las
prisiones para exigir respuestas
aseguran que no han cometido ningún
crimen yo pienso que el presidente lo
único que quiere es
numerosa y nada más para que la gente le
aplauda pues pero allí adentro hay gente
inocente gente que no ha hecho nada sea
cierto también han sacado pandilleros sí
es cierto no se lo voy a negar pero la
gran mayoría que está ahí son gente
inocente el salvador con seis millones y
medio de habitantes cerró el 2021 con la
tasa más baja de homicidios desde el fin
de su guerra civil en 1992 con 18
muertes por cada 100.000 habitantes
según datos oficiales el total de
muertes violentas
1.147 también representó una reducción
frente al 2020 cuando hubo mil 341 eeuu
reveló que el presidente salvadoreño
negoció en secreto una tregua con las
pandillas para lograr estas cifras
y vamos a revisar de norte a sur otras
noticias de nuestro continente que
ustedes deberían conocer esta semana
méxico se acerca a los 100 mil
desaparecidos desde que se detienen
registros según las autoridades hasta el
30 de marzo el país acumula 98 mil 423
personas no localizadas entre ellas está
el emblemático caso de los 43
estudiantes de ayotzinapa desaparecidos
en 2014 que todavía está sin resolver
precisamente esta semana los
investigadores revelaron que el ejército
manipuló pruebas del caso y bajemos al
centro américa de mano de la izquierda
latinoamericana que toma un nuevo aire
con la llegada de xiomara castró a la
presidencia de honduras el ex presidente
ecuatoriano rafael correa encontró una
oportunidad visitó tegucigalpa y acordó
asesorar a la mandataria hondureña en
materia económica
recordemos que correa es economista
y vamos al sur precisamente allí a
ecuador porque el actual presidente
guillermo lasso atraviesa una crisis
política que se vio materializada con la
renuncia de dos integrantes de su
gabinete por diferencias en su gestión
de una pugna de poder con el congreso le
piden disolver la asamblea de mayoría
opositora porque ésta no aprueba sus
programas algo a lo que él se niega
y vamos más al sur la división entre el
gobierno argentino se agudizó por el
acuerdo alcanzado entre el presidente
alberto fernández y el fondo monetario
internacional el presidente reconoció
que no habla con la vicepresidenta
veamos más en el informe que preparamos
para ustedes
la pareja presidencial argentina se
divorcia y como en casi todos los
divorcios hay una tercera parte esta vez
se trata del fondo monetario
internacional- la vicepresidenta a
cristina fernández de kirchner no estaba
de acuerdo con el pacto que el
presidente alberto fernández alcanzó con
el fm para refinanciar la deuda
adquirida por el ex presidente mauricio
macri lo que generó una ruptura que se
vio materializada a la hora de ratificar
el acuerdo en el congreso diputados
leales a cristina fernández votaron en
contra
fernández considera que el acuerdo con
el fmi es el primer paso hacia la salida
de la crisis económica evidente en una
inflación que sólo en febrero alcanzó el
47 por ciento y un índice de pobreza que
llega al 37 3% mientras que el
kirchnerismo encara el reclamo de los
argentinos que desconfían del fmi cuyos
pagos han obligado a varios gobiernos a
hacer recortes a planes sociales
llamando por partidas alimentarias para
los comedores común
el aumento de la asistencia social
porque hoy quién puede vivir con 16 mil
pesos que es el costo de la ayuda social
de un blanco
y además en la necesidad con la que se
viene reclamando hace años por hacer
lejos del gobierno los críticos señalan
a cristina fernández de querer controlar
al presidente una pugna de poder que ha
dejado estatuas de la ex primera dama
vandalizadas un acto que el presidente
repudio ella se ha ganado legítimamente
un lugar en nuestra historia y en
nuestro presente respetar las
instituciones y la convivencia en la
diversidad ideológica son una exigencia
que nuestra democracia nos impone
contrario al pacto los senadores
kirchneristas propusieron que las
obligaciones con el fm y que estaban en
riesgo de caer en default o cesación de
pagos este año las pagarán los
argentinos que han evadido impuestos y
tienen bienes y dinero en el exterior
para ello se levantaría el secreto
fiscal en una señal de reconciliación
fernández apoyó el proyecto de ley y
vamos a chile las momias de la cultura
chinchorro son las más antiguas del
mundo datan aproximadamente del año 5000
50 antes de cristo- actualmente se
exponen en el museo arqueológico san
miguel de azapa en arica la cultura
chinchorro poseía una avanzada práctica
de momificación que se puso un elaborado
culto a los muertos y amplios
conocimientos de la anatomía humana
las momias más antiguas del mundo son
las de la cultura chinchorro se
conservan en el museo arqueológico de
san miguel de azapa en la región de
arica en chile
muy cerca de la costa donde fueron
descubiertas desde la región donde vivía
el pueblo chinchorro que dejó huellas de
extraordinarias de sus rituales
funerarios 2000 años antes de las momias
egipcias
la importancia y la relevancia que tiene
esta cultura es que ellos tienen el
sistema de momificación más antiguo del
mundo que data de diez mil ocho mil años
ya es mucho más antigua que la comida
egipcia la razón por la que las momias
están tan conservadas es porque
estuvieron olvidadas durante miles de
años en el árido desierto de atacama y
en condiciones climáticas excepcionales
desde el año pasado las momias
chinchorro figuran en la lista del
patrimonio mundial de la unesco un
reconocimiento internacional de la
importancia de esta cultura que hicieron
esto fuera una identidad de la región
me encantaría que fuera yo creo que cada
día es más pero que la gente se ha ido
apropiando de los chinchorros y ven esta
importancia ven esta diferencia que son
gente tan antigua a diferencia de los
egipcios que modificaban a reyes y
nobles estos pueblos antiguos realizaban
este rito funerario sin distinción de
edad o estatus y me despido con cine
disney recibió el óscar a la mejor
película animada por encanto un filme
que celebra la cultura colombiana aquí
los ciudadanos estamos orgullosos de
haber sido reflejados de manera
diferente por hollywood todos los
colombianos y especialmente los
argentinos estamos felices con este
logro esto no es un logro sólo para
talento sino para todo el país mostrar
eso esa cara tan positiva gracias por
acompañarnos en esta emisión de aquí
américa en la producción estuvo joan y
algo de lo envíenme sus comentarios en
redes sociales a la dirección que ven en
sus pantallas y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]